we can now discuss something that has
been uh non-discussable for a little bit
i'm going to be very uh careful and
intentional about exactly what is said
in the next couple of minutes
because i don't think this is my story
to tell
don't think that i've got any opinion
outside of uh what uh what we're gonna
read here block fi
which many people know a large investor
in uh has reached a
resolution settlement
with regulators
over
regulatory questions around number of
their products this is
probably
i think and i don't want to speak here
but i think this is the largest
settlement
in crypto history to date and
what we can do here is we're going to
pull up maybe let's start with um
uh with zach's tweets zach just put out
a bunch of tweets here so i'm just going
to read them and then we'll discuss huge
day for block finder interest bearing
product the block fight interest account
we've reached a resolution with both the
sec and state regulators that identifies
a clear path forward for folks to earn
interest on their crypto my point of
view below
it says that he's gonna outline three
things why settlement is needed what
this means for our clients and where do
we go from here
first i'd like to note that client funds
are safeguarded and accessible now block
file will continue to grow and build no
client funds are being utilized to pay
for the settlement
next this settlement is related just to
our blockfly interest account product
for u.s clients our other products are
including wallet personalized yield
loans credit card and trading are
unaffected by this settlement our
institutional products including
blockfly prime are also unaffected
why the settlement is needed we have
worked tirelessly over the past several
months to secure this clarity for our
clients and i am not being hyperbolic
when i say this with the key focus of
every single conversation we had with
regulators
what does this mean for clients if you
have a block fight interest account
today you will continue to earn interest
as you always have it will be a pause
where u.s folks cannot add new funds
into their block fight interest account
and can't open a new block fight
interest account
outside the united states clients can
continue to deposit into and open new
block fight interest accounts
where are we headed we will be starting
the registration process with the sec
for block fight yield new crypto
interest bearing security
then once complete block fight interest
accounts will convert to block fight
yield and new deposits and client
signups in the us will be enabled in the
interim all clients with funds in a
block fight interest account will
continue to earn interest as they always
have
our new product block five personalized
yield will also remain available
throughout the registration process
huge thank you to our incredible team at
blockfy who has worked tirelessly on
this matter since last summer and thank
you to all our clients we'll continue
working hard to deliver more value to
you through our products and services i
encourage everyone to read the official
press release from blockfi available
here and as always please don't hesitate
to contact block fright support with any
questions you may have
now if we go and we actually pull up the
press release itself press release
states that block file lending a
subsidiary of block fi inc has entered
into a resolution with the us sec north
american securities administration
administrators association providing
regulatory clarity and a path forward
for clients across the united states who
want to earn interest on their crypto
assets it's part of the resolution block
fight intends to file or confidentially
submit a registration statement on form
s1 with the sec for the offering of
block fi yield which is anticipated to
be the first sec registered crypto
interest bearing security
we then have a quote from zach says from
the day we started block file we have
always known that strong engagement with
regulators would be critical for the
adoption of financial services powered
by cryptocurrencies today's milestone is
yet another example of our pioneering
efforts in security regulation uh i'm
sorry in securing regulatory clarity for
the broader industry and our clients
just as we did for our first product the
crypto back loan we intend for block
fight yield to be a new sec registered
crypto interest bearing security which
will allow clients to earn interest on
their crypto assets blackfy cooperated
with the government's investigation and
implemented remediation actions both the
sec and state level agreements contain
no admission or denial of wrongdoing or
liability as part of the resolution
existing u.s block by interest bearing
accounts and it goes on to describe
exactly what's going to happen which she
tweeted as well
and of course all other products will
continue now what i am about to discuss
here is my personal opinion i don't
speak for the company i don't have as
much information as the executive team
has etc i was not privy to the
conversations with regulators so this is
my personal opinion obviously i've
talked to zach i've talked to other
members of the block fight team but
i do think that these a couple important
points here
first regulators are trying to figure
this out i think most regulators have
good faith efforts they are trying to
understand what's happening in this
industry trying to understand what the
technology is trying to understand what
users and consumers want and also how
businesses can be built here economic
value can be created jobs can be created
and users can be serviced so i think
that you've got to understand
in a fast growing complex industry
regulators are trying to figure it out
just as much as companies and
entrepreneurs and investors and users
are trying to figure it out as well
there's education that goes on and also
understanding
the second thing
is there obviously now is a bifurcation
us-based users are going to be treated
one way international users are going to
be treated a different way that is for
some period of time let's call that a
temporary period of time the
international users are going to be able
to continue to access the blockfy
interest accounts we'll be able to
create those accounts be able to add to
those accounts uh and kind of business
as usual
inside of the united states
there's a pause for a moment i'll get
back to that pause in a second when that
pause will be listed uh lifted there's a
new product that block file has called
personalized yield what that means is
that you can still get yield on your
assets it's just done in a more
personalized way block five will not say
hey everyone is gonna get x percent
instead you go to block five you say
here's my assets here's who i am etc
what can you give me and then there's a
negotiation that goes on
and they'll quote you a price and you
can either take it or leave it
now the pause is because blockfy is
going to as they mention here submit an
s1 not for the company to be
publicly traded
but an s1 for the actual interest
bearing account which means that
the interest bearing account will now be
garnered as a security
there are pros and cons to that there's
a lot more transparency there's a lot
more reporting there's a lot more
oversight and regulation etc
it makes it a little bit harder to do
business obviously right because of all
that reporting and oversight et cetera
but again based on those discussions uh
both groups thought this was the best
path forward and so blackfyre's going to
go ahead and do that once that s1 is
actually approved then the
pause on the block fight interest
accounts will be lifted uh is kind of
the the process at which this happens
and so those accounts will then be
registered securities be governed that
way uh be operated that way and we'll be
off to the races now
what's interesting is
when you look at these interest bearing
accounts obviously your bank
provides interest in an interest bearing
account on your dollars those are not
considered securities and therefore
those financial institutions do not have
to meet certain regulatory
kind of requirements there are other
types of regulatory requirements that
they have to meet as a bank and
other types of regulators that they have
to appease
but in this case this interest bearing
account with crypto
as the currency or or the unit of
account will be considered security on
the block by platform
now of course
that specific uh
situation
again is interesting because it now sets
a precedent that uh this specific
product uh is going to be treated much
more like a debt security uh than it
would a currency based savings account
like in the traditional banking system
and so i think that uh what jumps to my
mind again this is my personal opinion
is that i've said over and over and over
again that the one of the critiques of
the crypto industry is that there are no
rules is that there is no um
kind of oversight it's the wild wild
west you can do whatever you want people
are breaking the law people are
violating securities law et cetera but i
continue to say that there is more
regulation in the crypto industry than
there is in the legacy finance industry
people say what do you mean and what
i've always said is that let's use two
examples
if you are in the state of new york
wall street new york city manhattan is
the heart of the financial system
globally it's the capital of the finance
system
if you want to start a crypto company
you have to get more regulatory
approvals than if you simply want to
start a fintech a financial technology
company that isn't a bank
so if you want to do lending or savings
accounts or other types of things in
many cases if it's with crypto you
actually have to go and you've got to
get the bit license which is the
additional step in the regulatory
process to be able to be allowed to
operate as a business in new york serve
new york based customers these other
businesses do not need to do that and so
from that perspective specifically
crypto companies have more regulation
the second thing is that the asset
themselves
if i go to dinner tonight and i spend
dollars or i spend a foreign currency i
simply pay for the meal i tip the waiter
or waitress and i pay my sales tax and
i'm good to go
if i then go try to spend bitcoin or
cryptocurrencies
then what ends up happening is i pay for
the meal i tip the waiter a waitress i
pay my sales tax but i also am subject
to capital gains on those assets as well
and so whether you are looking at it
from operating a business inside of the
financial capital of the world or you
are talking about as a user anywhere in
the united states trying to actually
spend these assets then there is more
regulation there's kind of over
uh
or there's additional regulation
compared to the traditional system now
another example now we can add this as a
third one is that if i have an interest
bearing account with dollars in them and
i earn that interest it's not considered
a security and so the issuer or the uh
the person who's offering me that
product uh doesn't have to operate as if
it's security and i as an individual
don't have to have any concerns around
securities or securities laws because
i'm simply using that uh
with a us dollar based interest account
now what we are seeing is that if
somebody was to offer the same type of
interest account but a different asset
instead of dollars or some other foreign
currency now with a digital currency or
a cryptocurrency uh it is treated as a
security and so again people will debate
pros and cons should this should this
not happen whatever but again there is
more
of a bar to be met for crypto companies
so now we have three examples as to how
this is more regulated rather than less
regulated
now the other thing that i think is
important here
is
what we are watching
is this is a big number right it's 100
million dollars uh in terms of the
settlement and i think that what people
are going to
uh begin to realize is that there's a
lot of companies
that were very early they were very
innovative they pushed the pace of
innovation they were pioneers in many
cases uh and those companies that were
considered startups are now maturing
they're growing up they're becoming uh
the leaders of this uh fast-growing
industry blockfi is obviously one of
them they're a multi-billion dollar
business they service a lot of customers
they custody a lot of assets uh they
serve customers everything from the
largest institutions in the world all
the way down to uh literally an
individual with tens of dollars
and as they do that one obviously as
they describe in the twitter thread and
in the uh press release they have to be
able to engage with regulators they have
to be able to um you know have those
conversations and
continue to talk to the people in which
uh have oversight over them but also
these businesses because they are at the
leaders in these fast growing industries
they
drive very large financial outcomes they
do that for investors they also do that
from a revenue standpoint they do that
for users as well there's a lot of folks
who have been using the block by
interest account as one example for a
long time
and they were earning high rates of
interest and those high rates of
interest uh ended up being pretty
material because they were getting paid
in cryptocurrencies that also went up
over time as well and so i think that
there's a ton to unpack here i don't
think that uh i am going to uh be the uh
the only person who has opinions here i
don't think that uh i've got some uh
unique uh perspective uh
other than anyone else but i do think
that uh this is a very very big deal
obviously the largest settlement that i
know of in the crypto industry to date
and uh 100 million dollars is a lot of
money but also there now is a
framework there's a precedent
in terms of how this product is going to
be treated
and uh what it begins to ask is there's
a lot of other companies in the space
who have these products what are they
going to do right are they going to go
ahead and follow suit are they going to
uh you know kind of have a different
take with regulators we'll see